là l'infirmière est venu puis je me suis
dit voyons on dirait je me parlais dans
ma tête laiss aller ça va bien aller ça
va être correct par pour la peser par
d'habitude je va toujours avec autres
parce que pas que j'ai peur qu' leur
arrive quel chose mais je sais pas faut
toujours je les vois surtout quand qu'
vienent de Na on veut pas trop s'en
séparer fait je me parlais pour pas y
aller mais c'est un moment donné on
dirait que ça été plus fort que moi
cétait comme si j'avais vraiment mauvais
Fing les infirmières il y
avaiit il y en a tu sais ils l'ont vu la
personne se promener puis tout le monde
se posait un peu des questions c'était
qui cette personn là moi je l'avais pas
vu jusqu'àatts qu' rentre dans ma
chare
puis quand que j'étais arrivé au poste
puis que je cherchais les balances il
ont tout de suite allumé que c'était
cette madame là puis qu'il l'avait
jamais vu puis aussi il avait remarqué
qu'il était bien infirmière fait que les
les filles sont il ont aussi essayer de
chercher puis il était aussi ébranlé que
moi fait que je suis tout de suite allé
vers les escaliers en courant pour
descendre vous avez couru en fait à la
vcous de Victoria oui c'est ça puis
arrivé en bas c'est là que j'ai entendu
un monsieur
dire là c'est vague là j'étais j'étais
trop trop énervé mais j'ai entendais un
monsieur il y avait aussi une madame qui
parlait puis le monde était comme il
trouvait ça épouvantable qu' une petite
fille comme ça sorte pas de chapeau
nu
pied parce qu'il faisait pas si chaud
que ça non plus fait que c'est là que
j'ai dit c'est ma fille est où le monde
comprenait pas j'ai dit je viens je
viens d'accoucher l'infirmière me le
volé tu sais fait que je suis sorti deh
plus c'était l'hystérie totale il y a un
monsieur qui est allé voir l'agent de
sécurité pour appeler le 91 pour les
photos puis sa tout le monde s'est
entraîné il ont resté là il ont resté
tard pour donner leur version des fits
aussi après
on a vraiment eu l'aide de la population
puis on est vraiment content ouais
l'alerte a été sonnée un peu parce qu'on
avait identifié le suspect la voiture ça
c'est grâce aux gens qui étaient dehors
qui ont reconnu la voiture puis qui ont
coopéré avec nous puis la photo un coup
qu'elle a été mis sur Facebook et
partagé c'est pour ça que les jeunes
l'ont vu puis ont reconnu la dame fait
que c'est sûr que c'est ça qui qui l'a
sauvé on était avec les enquêteurs notre
famille puis à chaque fois le téléphone
sonnait là on espérait que ça soit une
bonne nouvelle mais tu saisut pas ça
sonne souvent puis souvent c'est juste
pour faire un suivi pu n ten au courant
puis là quand qu' sonné le cœur t'arrête
à chaque fois puis là on a entendu un
policier crier on a le bébé et là là on
dirait que tout le monde s'est mis à
crier tout le monde pleurait
c'était vraiment un beau m c'est encore
mieux qu'un naissance c'est comme ça
avait
euh j'ai pas de mot et puis quand les
policiers sont arrivés j'avais assez
hâte qu' arrive le séit long juste le
temps maison l'avait pas vu on pouvait
pas le croire puis je vouis voir é Corre
puis en non les policiers pleurai les
enquêta les médecins les tout le monde
tout le monde était content du
déroulement des événements puis de la
petite
Victoria qu vous l'avez eu dans vos bras
ben ma première chose que j'ai faite
c'est que je l'ai regardé ça était
correct qui a un médecin qui est venu
l'examiner aussi pour être sûr que
était correct puis je l'ai nourri parce
qu'elle avait faim
elle pleurait pas rien elle pleurait pas
non c'est comme si rien était comme ça
promen en carrosse ouais je pense
qu'elle s'est rendu compte de rien trop
petite aussi puis c'est tant mieux ouais
ben moi j'espère que ça me rendra pas
trop
paranoïque
mais ben je pense que ça va
m'apprendre que on peut les rapidement
d'apprécier nos enfants
tout aussi des fois on est fatigué ou
quoi que ce soit mais toujours en
profiter au maximum peu importe les
journées ou
est plus peut-être comme je
disais c'est pas parce que quelqu'un a
un uniforme que faut faire confiance à
100 % faut se méfier poser plus de
questions fait c'est s je vais être
encore plus
prudente